[Music]
history has not been kind to horses many
people talk about the 600,000 people
killed in the American Civil War but
some overlooked that the horse and mule
death toll is over 1 million in
Victorian England it was not uncommon
for trolleys and factories to work
horses until they dropped dead sometimes
in the middle of busy streets up and
into the 20th century horses brutally
stood with a side-by-side in wartime and
in civilian life and even today where
the average person almost never
interacts with horses in their everyday
lives we still see the horse constantly
in art and media for every culture with
horses there's a different meaning
applied to them in ancient Greece the
animal was a sign of aspiration in
connection to the gods which we can see
most clearly in Pegasus the Nordic
people believed in horses for day and
night called from facts II and skin
facts II who traversed land and sea and
moved with the wind
Gandalf's horse Shadowfax was directly
influenced by this Norse mythology but
in this video I want to talk about a
specific horse mythology the American
version one deeply ingrained in the
modern American conscious American
cinema has historically used the horse
as a symbol of status masculinity and
mastery over nature and to explore this
particular meaning of the horse
historians don't have to look at ancient
paintings and stories like with older
civilizations we can actually very
clearly see the symbolism of horses in
the movies and TV of the last 100 years
up and into the current day so what do I
mean by the horse as a symbol of mastery
the horse provides the perfect
opportunity to show man's control over
nature for one thing horses are very
wild and unpredictable they're too large
to keep in the home like a dog and
strong enough to easily kill a human so
they are a worthy opponent to control
bronc riding reminds us of their
strength because they're genuinely
dangerous in certain contexts despite
these characteristics we still manage to
tame them on a massive scale we are able
to control them send them into battle
and use them as tools more so than any
other animal of that size and unlike
cattle or other livestock they can
easily be mounted there's nothing that
shows mastery over nature more than
being on top of a large wild beast
directing it where you want it to go
riding at a higher vantage point than
pedestrians to showcase my point how do
the creators of the Planet of the Apes
series show that the monkeys are
dominating the planet are no longer
simply wild animals and are taking
charge this sin
image tells us everything we need to
know about how much the monkeys are
evolving and that's because of all the
meaning associated with riding a horse
and some of the earliest forms of cinema
we can see how the horse human
relationship reinforces horse riding as
a symbol of mastery in 1878
Eadweard Muybridge rigged 24 cameras on
a racetrack with trip wires that went
off as a horse galloped by he wanted to
see if all four of the horses feet come
off the ground at once during gallop
something that happens too quickly for
the human eye to see on its own this
experiment tries to master the movement
of the horse in a way more bridge was
taming the wild unknown aspects of
horseback riding and turning them into
something controllable by the camera and
by humans the cameraman is a master of
the world around him capturing the horse
as he wants to make an unknown part of
nature known this experiment became one
of the first primitive forms of a motion
picture and it paved the way for cinema
to contain the wild nature of the horse
from then on the horse in movies
reflected a thing to master a wild
beasts to represent who could control it
and who couldn't these early ideals of
horseback riding found their way into
Hollywood particularly in the western
genre in these movies the horse
showcases the mastery and control of the
typical Western hero the horse is an
extension of these masterful riders who
could effortlessly handle their horses
in dangerous situations a classic
example of control through horseback
riding comes from John Wayne and
stagecoach throughout the movie the
people riding the stagecoach are being
controlled by others they either change
plans to avoid an Apache attack or
because the military made them do so
symbolically it makes sense that these
two outside forces would control the
fate of the stagecoach both the Apache
and the military are the men actually
riding on horseback
unlike the stagecoach where the horses
are in front pulling the people behind
them John Wayne famously abandons the
stagecoach to ride one of the horses
himself giving the visual cue that he
has now taken control by becoming a man
on a horse in this final battle scene
the military and stagecoach members
shoot the Apache off of their horses
indicating that now the Apache are no
longer in control there's actually a
running gag in American westerns where
men are dragged by horses here we see a
complete reversal of the traditional
roles because the horse isn't controlled
instead of the man this trope is always
reserved for the characters not in
control the ones without the suave and
mastery of the traditional American hero
either they can't control their horse or
they ride the horse in a bastardized way
maybe they're too
to ride the horse themselves or they
have to fake riding all together you'll
never see John Wayne riding a horse in
any way other than one that shows cool
manly control which brings up another
key aspect of horseback riding in
American cinema in the real world
horseback riding is one of the most
gender-neutral competitions to exist
today in the Olympics equestrian events
are some of the few where men and women
compete against each other but an
American cinema that is not the case
with some notable exceptions women on
horses are few and far between
especially at the peak of the western
genre this phenomenon is historically
accurate since the men had the agency
money and land to own their own horses
we can still feel this masculine
perception of horseback riding in modern
media it explains why this joke works
anything is possible when your man
smells like old spice and not a lady I'm
on a horse the ideal man is one that
rides a horse any movie that puts women
on a horse usually challenges this norm
of men on horseback in Brokeback
Mountain Laraine first sees jack ball
she's riding a horse and he's on foot
already establishing a reversal of
gender roles on the horse she physically
towers over him this role reversal
continues when she approaches him at the
bar to hit on him and act traditionally
done by the man throughout the movie
their positions in the marriage get
challenged she's the one operating the
company with the traditional office desk
while he fights for control in the home
the initial power dynamic of her on
horseback establishes masculinity in the
movie she rides the show horse showing
her power wealth and control while Jack
is thrown off a bull showing his lack of
control and a hint at his
non-traditional male role Westworld
shows just how much the hosts are
breaking the rules by having Dolores a
docile female character become a horse
riding gunslinger with horses so closely
associated with masculinity control and
power it's no surprise that characters
will also kill other people's horses to
assert dominance this power grab gets
done most famously in The Godfather and
the Public Enemy if a horse shows
control killing the horse removes the
control there are also racial undertones
to horseback riding it was illegal for
black people to buy a horse in many
parts of the antebellum south
such a loss seems unnecessary because
black people did not have the money or
agency to own a horse in the first place
this redundancy implies that the law
existed as a symbolic gesture a reminder
by white Southerners that black people
should not have the status and power
associated with riding a horse Django
Unchained touches on the racial issues
of horseback ride
the simple act of being black and on a
horse challenges traditional portrayal
of men on horseback it's such a great
movie because it lets minority
characters have the same cool mastery
and control that was originally reserved
for white men the movie perfectly
showcases horseback riding as a power
dynamic right in the first scene there's
a power reversal where a horse
immobilizes a man the opposite of a man
controlling the horse many times in the
movie weaker characters are either
thrown off their horse or shot off their
horse but never Django when we watch the
movie we never consciously observe who
is riding the horse well or not but
these images play into subconscious
American ideas of mastery through
mastery of the horse we can feel how
much more controlled Django has compared
to the other white characters apart from
dr. King Schultz who can command his
horses at will we can feel how much more
control Django has compared to the other
white characters the KKK members can't
see for themselves so they let the horse
take control I can't see you can't see
so what all that matters is can the
fucking art see this Kate Kate Kate
charge feels like a comedic revision of
a similar scene in The Birth of a Nation
filmed in 1915 DW Griffith portrays
these KKK members much differently than
the easy to trick idiots in Django
Klansmen charge into town on horseback
to rescue Elsie from the hands of black
men on screen the epic and skillful
riding on a horse transforms these
Klansmen from an unruly mob into heroes
saving the day this movie uses horses to
show that KKK members as heroic and in
control and they disturbingly used their
mastery to attack and suppress black
people in the movie the cruelest irony
in both The Birth of a Nation and Django
Unchained is that horses themselves are
slaves they were tamed and forced to
work historically for white men in the
cinematic sphere controlling the horse
shows if their handler is a good master
with Django as a former slave his role
as a horseback rider and master is
confusing since it's a slave controlling
a slave this unnatural relationship
confuses characters throughout the movie
Django repeatedly does things a master
would do like whipping people and
manipulating people do I sound like a
fucking slave the horse symbolizes his
new role as a master of his domain but I
want to go further I want to suggest
that in some cases this symbolism of
horse riding exists past just the movies
it bleeds into real life you know that
it is special election day and
we do expect to see Senate candidate Roy
Moore arriving by horseback to the polls
is it a coincidence that Roy Moore a
conservative Republican wrote a horse to
the polls during his campaign in Alabama
I don't think so he rode that horse when
he didn't have to it was a symbolic
gesture he was trying to evoke American
perceptions of the West ones of mastery
and control now I'm not saying that
riding a horse to the polls is
necessarily a bad thing but I will say
that men on horseback particularly when
embodying old ideas of the American
cowboy evoke concepts of domination and
masculinity that are inherently
problematic in certain contexts a state
of emergency has been declared in the US
state of Virginia Jefferson they were
protesting the planned removal of a
Confederate monument from a city park
statues were taken down in New Orleans
after two years of court battles and a
heated violence I was in tears yesterday
to see that I would that hurt it hurts I
want America at heart
America has debated the removal of
Confederate monuments around the country
for the last several years
opponents of the statues claim that
these statues were not built as
memorials but rather to intimidate black
people and to reaffirm white supremacy
one aspect of these statues rarely
mentioned is the fact that these men are
very commonly on horseback
it's one thing to have these people
standing but the fact that they are on
horseback gives them a certain
mythological Authority like a John Wayne
Western hero a man on horseback
symbolizes a man in control a master of
his domain a person of wealth and status
physically above the pedestrians around
him but the mythologizing of these men
disguises a sinister history though some
Americans may look to these statues and
be reminded of admire Balestra heroes
other Americans may look at them and see
a reminder of the men on horses who
fought to keep their ancestors in Chains
after all the horse is itself a slave
taken from the wild and tamed to work as
a tool and the rider is his master
whether you feel it consciously or not a
Confederate white man riding a horse on
a monument evokes slavery imagery and a
historical look at riding in American
cinema shows how the design of these
statues makes them aggressive tools for
intimidation so what should we do about
them polls show America is torn on
whether to take them down
but there's more to consider than simply
whether they should stay the same or
whether
they should go away so there's a third
option the third option is we engage our
contemporary artists of this time we
have them make sculptures that exist in
the communities that they live in we
present those sculptures in the same
community squares where these robert e
lee sculptures exists we pull those
Robert Lee Lee sculptures down from the
pedestal bring them at the same level as
these new contemporary works and we
force these works to engage one another
Richmond Virginia has five Confederate
leaders on Monument Avenue including
Jefferson Davis robert e lee and
Stonewall Jackson but one other monument
commonly falls under the radar when
talking about these iconic centerpieces
tennis legend Arthur Ashe also has his
own statue on Monument Avenue despite a
much more modest design than his
Confederate counterparts their proposal
of his statue sparked a racial debate at
the time of its erection in the 1990s
this statue is a step in the right
direction
challenging Monument Avenue as a place
reserved for white Confederate leaders
even so I think Richmond has an
opportunity in the current political
climate to add other more challenging
monuments Monument Avenue follows the
tradition of white men in art
aristocrats in the 18th century commonly
commissioned portraits of themselves on
horseback to signify their importance
wealth and power it's designed for
domination it's it's a language designed
to make the sitter feel as though he
could ride this steep and control it
with a pinkie control it with the sheer
will of his mind it's a propaganda act
in response to these traditional
portraits artist Kendall Wylie has a
piece titled Napoleon leading the army
over the Alps Wiley's peace
recontextualizes the famous Napoleon
painting by replacing him with a black
man in contemporary clothing critiquing
the historical tradition of ignoring the
black cultural experience it
crystallized something that I'd been
thinking about for a very long time
which is that black men have been giving
very little in this world and that I as
an artist have the power and the
potential and the will to do something
about it because it's not just that
these Confederate heroes invoke slavery
imagery there's another opportunity with
the debate over these statues the
opportunity to make heroes out of people
that have historically been put to the
side and we go into the front entrance
of the museum and there's an amazing
sculpture of Teddy Roosevelt off
you guys know which one I'm talking
about David Roosevelt this in there with
one hand on the horse bold strong
sleeves rolled up I don't know if he's
bare chested but it kind of feels like
it and on the left hand side of him is a
Native American walkin and on the right
hand side of him as an African American
Walker and as we're moving up the stairs
getting closer to the sculpture my
oldest son who's 9 says dad how come he
gets to ride and they have to walk I
think an artist like kinda wily or Titus
kafar could create a great addition to
Monument Avenue with a statue that
rethinks who gets to ride on horseback
so I'm not saying you should feel bad
for liking classic cowboy movies some of
those movies are amongst the greats but
I am saying that the horse rider
relationship deserves a closer look
because it reveals subtleties in our
media and how we can make more powerful
and challenging art ok I'm done
preaching this stuff I'll get off my
high horse but there is one thing I
won't get off my high horse about as
some of you might know I'm actually a
software developer when I'm not making
videos I'm writing code and logging in
and out of tons of applications and
websites I keep all my passwords secure
and out of mind using - lean - lean is a
secure and easy to use password
protection service with over 10 million
users in the current tech landscape it
is definitely the best way to manage the
dozens of passwords you use on a regular
basis when you need to log in to a site
- lean automatically adds your secure
password and it works on all phones and
computers from iPhones to Windows
computers you can get these features for
free or dashlane premium gives you
unlimited password storage plus a VPN
for every device you use and dark web
monitoring to make sure your data is not
being bought and sold on the dark web
click the link in the description or go
to - lang comm slash now you see it to
download it for free and if you want all
those features you can use the coupon
code now you see it thanks for watching